hello today we're going to talk about
how to counter the king's Gambit so the
king's Gambit starts with E4 E5 and then
F4 defines the king's Gambit so white is
immediately giving up this Pawn allowing
us to take a free Pawn because in return
they're going to get some counterplay in
the center they're going to be able to
put their two pawns here and be pretty
happy so right away taking on F4 is uh
it's kind of dangerous you can
definitely get away with it but you have
to know what you're doing for sure so I
prefer and I'm going to recommend this
move D5 and what D5 does is It just
strikes white back you just takes a
punch and gives it right back so instead
of relieving any of the tension here we
just created more tension cuz either
side could have taken here and now
either side can take here so a lot of
tension going going on already two moves
into the game so D5 makes it a really
fun position and after D5 white already
has a lot of places they can mess up so
for example um here F takes E5 is a huge
mistake like already losing mistake
because after F takes E5 black has Queen
to H4 check and this is going to be a
big theme with the king's Gam
when white moves this F Pawn they're
opening up this diagonal towards their
King so Queen H4 is very deadly and the
only way to block it is to play G3 and
that doesn't help things cuz now there's
this fork and uh black is just
completely winning here winning a ton of
material in the next few
moves so F Tak E5 is bad and also a move
like Knight to F3 trying to keep the
status quo in the center try not to do
anything crazy also isn't great because
after d takes E4 I takes E5 um that
Knight's under attack it has to move
we're just going to keep harassing that
Knight we play Knight to
D7 and if they trade that's going to
favor us because at the end of the day
we have a pawn in the center and white
doesn't so White's going to try to
counter in the center by putting their
own Pawn there and we just on assant
they move too squares so we can on on
here and they take back we take on E5
and after all the dust settles we can
play this move Bishop to C5 and this is
so
important because this is stopping white
from castling and this is kind of the
goal of the opening is to get castled
and stop your opponent from castling so
here we stop white from castling and
we're ready to potentially bring this
Knight out and Castle within the next
few moves so Knights F3 is not anything
scary the real testing line here is to
play e takes D5 this is the only real um
move you'll see with any serious Kings
Gambit player um but after this move uh
it gives us some options um but the most
accurate way to play is just to take
this Pawn so we did a really funky way
of trading Pawns
uh having the both the Pawns in the
center like that we just left two pawns
hanging so if either side took yeah
other side could take the other Pawn
real weird situation here but this move
does come with a threat and that is
Queen to H4 because if we go back reason
we didn't play Queen H4 now is because
white has this move G3 which blocks the
check and harasses our Queen and we just
didn't gain anything from this queen H4
move G3 3 is probably a move that
actually helps white so Queen H4 is no
good actually take first because now
this Pawn is controlling the G3 square
and queen H4 is coming next so white is
more or less forced to play Knight to F3
which covers this H4 square and stops
Our Queen H4
idea after this move we're going to
continue our development we play Knight
to F6 and this Knight does a good job of
attacking this Pawn on D5 it's important
to not that we could have taken this
Pawn with the queen this is possible but
after a move like Knight C3 wait gain
some time kicking our Queen around so
ideally when we want to keep our Queen
out of the center unless white gives
something in return so after Knight to
F6 white has some options we're going to
look at three options here C4 trying to
hold on to this pawn bishop to B5 check
and Bishop to C4
so first let's look at C4 if white can
hold on to this Pawn that looks like it
would be pretty good this is a a very
powerful Pawn but what we're going to do
here is actually again strike back this
is kind of the theme of playing against
the Kings Gambit instead of being
passive and letting white have all the
fun we're going to be aggressive too
we're going to play the move
C6 and what C6 does is it gives white
this option of potentially taking on C6
which would improve our development so
if they took on C6 we would take back
with a
knight but what this also does is just
fight back in the center if we could get
this move in bring our KN towards the
center we're going to be very happy um
and if they don't take on C6 for example
if they play Move Like D4 well we can
just take on D5 and this is also a
pretty good situation because at the
start of this position white has a great
hold on the center and we fought back
with this move C6 and now we have a pawn
in the center and White's Center isn't
so uh menacing so this is uh kind of the
goal and white could take on
F4 we're just going to give a check and
castled and as usual if we can Castle we
should be pretty happy here the eval is
slightly better for black here because
White Center is on the verge of falling
apart it's very difficult to hold on to
all these pawns with Bishop to G4 coming
Rook to E8 Knight to C6 pressure on D4
and pressure down this e file it's going
to be very difficult for white to deal
with all these issues so after C4 again
we're going to meet that with
C6 and then if we go back one more
move and then if we go back one more
move to Bishop to
C4 against this uh we're actually just
going to take on D5 so we have some
other options but taking on D5 is the
simplest um we again want to get castled
as soon as possible I'm going to keep
saying that because it's very
important um and taking on D5 kind of
helps us clear up the center a little
bit again that pawn on D5 is really
annoying and we don't want to just leave
it there so we want to fight back that's
why we just take it cuz in this line a
move like C6 isn't necessary because we
can just take it we don't have to play a
move like C6 instead our Knight can
still come to C6 later so after Knight 6
D5 White's going to Castle and what's
important here is that we don't let
white take over this e file and use it
to their advantage we don't want to let
them keep our King in the center but
pressured on this eile that stops us
from castling so right away we plug this
e file with Bishop to
E6 and after Bishop to E6 um we can play
a lot of moves we'll just say they play
Bishop to B3 and now there's a lot of
flexibility in this position so what I
really like about this position we can
play Knight to C6 and we could actually
Castle either side we could play Bishop
to D6 or Bishop to E7 and either Castle
King side or play Queen to D7 and Castle
Queen side and both of these are very
good very fun options um and there's a
lot to play for again it's very
aggressive there's there's no sitting
back and waiting it's just it's a lot
more fun uh to play like this so um
against Bishop C4 we're just going to
take on D5 that kind of relieves the
tension in the center and if we develop
we're going to be ready to Castle and
have a great
position so the last move we're going to
look at is Bishop to B5 check so
immediately
put our King in danger we have to choose
what to do if we do something a little
bit passive like we bring our Knight to
D7 this may not be as good because white
can Castle very quickly and try to use
this e file again to keep our King in
the center and cause some issues for us
so after Bishop B5 check again we're not
going to sit back and be passive we're
going to be aggressive Fight Fire with
Fire and play C6
so what C6 does very similar to that C4
line is it helps us if what takes to
bring that Knight to C6 so for example
if they take we're ready to take back
the
Knight and then if white plays a move
like
D4 um it's also important to note here
that castling we're setting up kind of a
trap here castling is really bad it
actually loses on the spot because we
always want to pay attention to check
captures and threats and undefended
pieces so if you look at the undefended
pieces here this bishop sticks out like
a sore thumb and here Queen to B6 is
both a check and it attacks the
undefended piece so it wins the game so
anyway um D4 is probably a better option
instead of castling here and after D4 a
move like Bishop to D6 is uh very solid
again preparing to Castle holding on to
this pawn and developing a great move
and if castles castles we should be very
happy with this position our Bishop's
ready to go to G4 we're pretty much done
with our development and our King is
very very safe here on
G8 the last thing I want to mention is
because this pin it looks very enticing
for white to play D5 and attack the pin
piece but here we have a nice little
tactic Knight takes
D5 but here we have a nice little
D5 because it looks like the queen is
protecting it but if the queen takes we
have Bishop to B4 check a discovered
check on the queen and that's going to
be game over he's going to lose his
queen and the
game so that was a quick overview of how
to beat the king's Gambit with this
counter Gambit called the falkbeer
counter Gambit with D5 thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video